oh
guitar
last night we didn't do anything
live here the person that was born
okay well one thing I will tell you is
we didn't do anything last night no
worries neighbors are calling in again
that thing said the tickets get
expensive we got to come back out here
and you know the music keeps coming up I
understand yeah we'll definitely turn it
down I mean you're probably off maybe
like very low volume
it's not allowed to four people sounds
good no worries yeah we should have I
thought we were gonna talk to them
before but yeah maybe do a lap with your
name yeah that's a good idea do you live
here one of them okay
my name is Elliott
e-l-l-i-o-t-t and then Lund l u n
uh
uh
oh my God uh
my my number is very similar to my mom
that happens to the best
happens to board you guys are lucky the
little lady who lived there was gone now
I think that's a rental property now
okay yeah we definitely
I apologize
what's that you guys obviously know the
drill right yeah
that would that would be a good idea
yeah it would be it definitely
um since you guys live here you're
responsible for the music okay so we
have to come back out what's a noise
take it up to these days oh God it's
like 350 people yeah
later at night it gets the more
expensive it gets okay so spend the
money on beer instead not on tickets
yeah keep the music down have a good
party make sure everyone's over 21. yeah
if we do have to come back out here you
two guys are each kid got it I
understand
thank you all right have a good one take
care guys yeah thank you that semester
and in some cases like when we get here
and that stereo's going yeah I would
also go contact them because it was
non-specific and if I'm warning them I
better go fucking warn them true and is
that that's the bottom Roadhouse there
which one here that one that one's up on
uh goes through that driveway the guy's
walking right there oh yeah
that side there guarantee this area is
going to come right back on as soon as
we leave I saw that big tall JBL on the
back patio there it's always good okay
I'll come with you
I'm gonna walk up or do you wanna
just it wouldn't be fair you know if
you're one of these guys you better warn
them
Moscow 11.
[Applause]
still on the apartment Channel
Moscow 111.
we're clear of 1127 King Road we're
going to be out at 11 22 Queen Road same
problem
cancer
hey guys can you send someone out who
lives here please
sorry you can always call us later and
ask in case it gets turned in here
it's a business line sweet thank you you
bet
foreign
's coming to the door
yeah I look took one look at that
speaker I said hmm
foreign
a lot of guys trying to argue private
property access
correct me if I'm wrong was the way I
did it there find one responsible have
everyone else hold them accountable if I
gotta come back here they're getting the
ticket
it's on them to nip everyone else in the
budget and if they don't come out we
just contact landlords
or we come back the next day or
the next time you work
just note that lack of cooperation does
not go a long ways with us
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
interesting
how are you good how are you good is
this your place yeah perfect
yeah right there yeah nothing against
having a party once Neighbors start
calling in they have an issue here uh
you go to school uh yeah
okay so I'll tell you the same thing I
told them you probably know the drill
right actually no oh okay so usually at
least for me I'll give you a verbal
warning uh once I have neighbors calling
in he's too loud for your serving a
piece yeah nothing against having
parties nothing against having people
over who are over here to drink but
again once we start disturbing the
neighbors yeah always take it as up to
300 yeah somewhere around 300 400 bucks
that being said this is your place
someone holds you responsible they get
it more expensive later it gets
yeah we already warned them too so um
and if I do have to come back here
uh
tickets
is this 11 22 here yeah okay
I'd much rather you spend that 300 bucks
on beer or something funny yeah yeah
thank you I appreciate it
that being said warnings
don't do it again yep I'd hate to come
back in a few hours so yeah any
questions for me no all right take care
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right who's who's responsible here
who's responsible here whose house is
this
[Music]
just need to talk to a homeowner or a
renter or whoever's house this is I'm
one of the people around here okay
gotcha you guys are warned for the noise
last night sounds like same type of
thing you guys are having a party cop
that came out you weren't here last
night last night we didn't do anything
is there an Elena Shepard that lives
here who's Elena Shepard the person that
was born for the noise last night
okay one thing I will tell you we didn't
do anything last night no worries uh
neighbors are calling in again saying
music's too loud okay all I need you
guys to do is turn it down sounds good
that being said the tickets get
expensive we got to come back out here
and you know the music keeps coming up
and neighbors keep calling it fair
enough yeah we'll definitely turn down
you're probably off maybe like very low
volume okay no yeah yeah you can have a
party you can have music just not loud
enough to where people are calling and
saying hey
we're gonna go talk to them before yeah
maybe do a lap with your neighbors let
them know what's up that's a good idea
yeah you live here one of them okay let
me grab your name my name is Ellie it's
e-l-l-i-o-t-t last name blund l-u-n-d-h
middle initial uh I have two middle
names I'll just give me uh both uh PF
date of birth for you 99.
good phone number I can reach at uh
uh
what's the area code on that uh Eric
okay so it's
oh yeah my my number is very similar to
my mom so I can feed him that happens to
the best
okay I got you oh yeah yeah we
definitely expect them I apologize
you're good
that would be a good idea
okay so you know the drill you know how
it goes of course
um since you guys live here you're
responsible for the music so we have to
come back out what's the noise complaint
to get up to these days
okay yeah
next time we'll definitely check them
with the neighbors yeah it gets the more
expensive damn okay so spend the money
on beer instead not on tickets keep the
music down have a good party make sure
everyone's over 21. if we do have to
come back out here you two guys are each
getting tickets I understand so it's on
the rest of you to make sure the party
stays down thank you yeah
take care guys enjoy the party
yeah I would also go contact them
because it was non-specific sure and if
I'm warning them I better go fucking
warn them true and is that that's the
bottom Roadhouse there which one here
yeah that one's up on uh walking right
there oh yeah that side there guaranteed
it's very beautiful right back well I
saw that big tall JBL on the back patio
there so I'll just go chat with him okay
uh yeah we'll walk up we'll start things
off on the Good Foot
be fair you know if you're wondering
yeah it's a good point
not to go 11.
master 111.
we're clear of 1127 King Road
something
how's it going guys
Casey
I'm just gonna loop around up here
hey there
is this your place man okay would you
mind going and getting somebody oh shit
yeah do you want to send her up back
here I apologize we knocked at the front
door no one came yep thanks man
yeah I look took one look at that
speaker I said hmm
foreign
private property access
the way I've always done it and correct
me if I'm wrong was the way I did it
there find one responsible have everyone
else hold them accountable if I got to
come back here they're getting the
ticket
because then it's on them to nip
everyone else in the bud because they
know
we come back the next day or
next time you work yeah
there's nothing a lot of cooperation
does not go a long ways with us
downstairs to the back deck interesting
stairs to the back deck interesting
how are you good how are you good is
this your place yeah perfect you know
why we're here uh I assume noise noise
yeah yeah big speaker right there yeah
nothing against having a party once
Neighbors start calling in then we have
an issue Fair uh you go to school uh
yeah okay we're here senior senior okay
so I'll tell you the same thing I told
them you probably know the drill right
actually no oh okay so usually at least
for me I'll give you a verbal warning
okay uh once I have neighbors calling in
your music's too loud you're disturbing
the peace yeah nothing against having
parties nothing against having people
over who are over age to drink but again
once we start disturbing the neighbors
then we've got an issue yeah noise
ticket is up to 300. okay it's a pretty
expensive ticket I don't want to give
that to you that being said this is your
place so I'm going to hold you
responsible because it is your place
you're also responsible for everybody
here yeah so I'm gonna grab your info
yeah
um and if I do have to come back here uh
a 300 some dollar tickets come in your
way okay and only gets more expensive
from there is that fair yeah that's fair
absolutely
actually let's just do this what's a
good phone number for you
this 11 22 here yeah okay
I'd much rather you spend that 300 bucks
on beer or something fun then yeah right
yeah thank you I appreciate it yeah
that being said warnings
don't do it again yep I'd hate to come
back in a few hours and then have to
issue that so any questions for me yeah
all right have a great day thank you
foreign